hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Captain America number one video
just careful for spoilers from that
comic book everybody's freaking out it's
turned into a bit of a funny thing now
because of all the memes people are
creating so what's happened is is
Captain America has had a refresh in his
main comic Steve Rogers has not been
Captain America in the comics for a
while he's been old Steve Rogers he got
the serum taken out of him he took a lot
of the story arcs that he would normally
give to Nick Fury but because of DC
rebirth a lot of people think that
Marvel wanted to refresh
Captain America so they D aged him so we
got young Captain America again but
because Sam Wilson is now Captain
America with the vibranium shield and
they didn't want to take that away from
him they wanted a compelling twist so
mission accomplished
now everybody thinks and this is getting
to the spoiler part he is a Hydra agent
he's been Hydra this whole time but if
you've read comics you know they have
some of the most ridiculous set up
twists that they pay off later and
there's a big reversal so no I
definitely don't think that they're
saying the cap has been evil this whole
time I think there'll be some twists and
he'll be a triple agent or something
like that but when you read the actual
comic you kind of get an idea for where
they might be taking it now I haven't
read the whole series it hasn't been
released yet but there's all these
flashbacks it shows that Steve Rogers
mother was a victim of abuse she was
being recruited by a Hydra agent that
beat up her abusive husband so
considering this year is the 75th
anniversary of Captain America and
they're not gonna turn him into a Nazi
on his 75th birthday I think the story
is gonna be a larger exploration of the
true meaning of freedom like you can see
in the flashbacks the cap was the
perfect target for Hydra victim of abuse
someone who felt powerless Hydra comes
along and says hey we can make you feel
very powerful so there are a number of
ways that that could play out that lead
to this big reveal at the end of the
comic where he's like hail Hydra
I'm gonna talk a little bit about his
arc during Captain America Civil War of
the movie so careful for spoilers from
that he has that big conversation with
Tony Stark that ain't freedom he doesn't
want to sign the sokovia accords work
for the government because he's seen
what happens when government's agendas
change I mean he's really thinking of
the Nazis in that situation he has his
own idea of the
meaning of freedom and he doesn't want
to serve someone else's idea of freedom
worrying that that might end up changing
later if someone decides that their idea
of freedom isn't true freedom so I think
whatever ends up playing out over this
Captain America Ark that idea of freedom
will remain true to the character it's
just that the new backstory bits will
have him hopping around a bunch of
different places that you never expected
they want you to buy the comics so of
course the first issue has to like hook
everyone like oh my god what the hell
just happened but a lot of people have
said that you know mostly the people
that are getting upset about this are
non comic-book readers that's not
necessarily true
it reminds me of a big twist on the
flash season 2 TV show so careful for
spoilers from the flash with respect to
the Jay Garrick character there was a
big twist in the middle of the season in
Mark Waid longtime flash rider in
probably the most knowledgeable comic
book creator in the world like he has
this almost autistic memory for certain
comic book panels like he can pick out
specific comic book panels if you give
him the issue number that's how much he
knows comic books so he got really upset
with this big twist that posited that
Jay Garrick might have been hunter
zolomon zoom the whole time so he was
upset at the idea that Jay Garrick of
the TV shows had never been a hero but
then the producers of the flash TV show
were like wait wait wait we would never
do that to Jay Garrick we would never
trample over his memory just wait and so
then he backed up a little bit it was
like oh my god I'm sorry I didn't
realize that I was jumping the gun on
this so they wound up with this great
payoff for Jay Garrick at the end of the
season in Mark Waid was like thank you
so much I am so happy with the way
that's played out a lot of you are
probably familiar with the wally west
run that he wrote in the comics there
was a storyline called the return of
Barry Allen in it Barry came back and
was acting like a jerk so Mark Waid
tweeted this out the other day where
he's like if I tried to pull this off
today like the Captain America twist
people would kill me not even joking but
in the comics what ended up happening
during that return of Barry Allen arc is
that it was revealed that the
version of Barry Allen was secretly
eobard thawne masquerading as Barry
Allen so Wally West gives him the
beatdown here no Barry Allen you're just
an so if you feel bad
really upset about this hydro twist do
not get upset a lot of people have this
reaction even people who have been
reading comic books their whole life and
understand that this is just the way the
publishing game has played there has to
be a really interesting hook before they
pay it off and before some big reversal
where it's like oh cap was pretending to
be a double agent for Hydra when really
he was a triple agent trying to make
Hydra think that he was a double agent
but then there's a big reversal so there
are just so many winding twists that are
gonna happen in this story I think they
just wanted to make it really
interesting given what's happening with
DC rebirth right now because that's an
amazing story and any time DC does
something really amazing Marvel has to
try to do something amazing - it's just
the way the game is played but here's my
big question for you guys or it's not
really a question in the comments below
write in your funniest joke for this
text bubble here there have been some
really good ones but in related news if
you guys haven't seen it yet be sure to
go see x-men apocalypse I'm gonna be
doing an Easter Egg video soon there's
new Game of Thrones coming there's all
kinds of 90s x-men stuff that we have to
talk about so be sure to subscribe to
get that and hail Hydra I'm waiting to
hear stories from my friends that they
like spit their drink out and the person
they were sitting next to when they read
this like oh my god I can't believe he's
Hydra but while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my non-spoilery x-men apocalypse
review and you can click here for my DC
rebirth explainer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tight